josep lago chantal hébert alec
castonguay bonsoir
deux gros sujets incontournables dans
cette campagne ce soir au panel la
vaccination vaccination obligatoire ou
pas et l'environnement c'est ce qui a
dominé les échanges aujourd'hui je vous
fais en tant que monsieur trudeau je
rappelle aux gens si vous n'étiez pas là
en fin de semaine ou totalement absent
il ya eu des manifestations qui ont
perturbé son rassemblement vendredi
ils savent ce a donné lieu à des
échanges ensuite je vous fais entendre
simon vient tout de suite après
oui des gens qui ont des perspectives
extrêmement différentes mais c'est pour
ça que nous avons besoin d'entendre
clairement injuste les canadiens qui
rouspètent mais tous les canadiens qui
vont s'exprimer en votant ya rien que
ces gens là peuvent dire qu'ils vont me
faire reculer dans mon ambition pour les
canadiens pour lutter contre les
changements climatiques pour garder les
gens en sécurité avec les vaccinations
que je sais qu'il ya personne qui vont
reculer de faire ce qu'on doit faire
parce que il ya des boli qui a essayé de
leur faire peur
je me permettrai de s'aimer c'est mon
avis là je n'existe rien à personne de
suggérer au premier ministre
le poster de l'huile sur le feu
lorsqu'ils interpellent les manifestants
j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un d'aussi fâché
je vois vous l'imposé jeu reculerait pas
une attitude responsable
une rectitude rassembleuse une attitude
informative
serait davantage de nature à réduire ce
genre de risques que
le dessus d'un petit peu baveuse
alex cross avec vous monsieur blanchet
qui accueille monsieur trudeau d'une
aide de braquet ces gens là qu'en pensez
vous j'ai failli m'étouffer dans mon
café quand j'ai vu qu'ils françois
blanchet accuser quelqu'un d'autre
d'avoir une attitude un peu baveuse
c'est un peu surprenant et peut-être
qu'ils françois blanchet n'a pas assisté
aux mêmes manifestations que ce à quoi
on était confrontés les journalistes qui
suivent la caravane libéral justin
trudeau on parle pas de manifestants à
distance qui brandissent des pancartes
qui ont un point de vue différent sur
les politiques publiques ça ce serait
effectivement peut-être des places et
l'autre commencé à dire on reculera pop
et on veut rendre leur tenir tête là on
est face à des robes visiblement
organisé parce que plusieurs de ses
figures la suivent justin trudeau d'un
endroit à l'autre peu importe au pays
quand même j'apprends beaucoup
d'investissement pour faire ça et là on
est dans des dessins assez disgracieuses
le de gens qui brandissent des pancartes
pour prendre le premier ministre
on lui en cris des insultes racistes à
ce qu'il y
protège le premier ministre et ses
gardes du corps entre autres et donc je
peux comprendre justin trudeau après la
troisième quatrième ou cinquième de ce
type de manifestation le dit je vais pas
reculer je vais tenir bon bout et ça
sans même lui donner de l'énergie là sur
le chemin électorale mais voilà
et donc je m'attends que je suis pas
certain que qu'il va changer d'attitude
disons le comme ça wesh attal
il ya des journalistes qui était
vendredi soir à bolzano périodes où ça a
été particulièrement spectaculaires les
unes manifestation et qui avait couvert
des campagnes électorales comme vous et
moi depuis des décennies et qui
n'avaient jamais vu un tel niveau de
violence dans le discours et d'enfants
ce qu'on appelle le langage corporel on
n'est pas là les manifestations contre
les premiers ministres dans notre jeu
mais on est ailleurs
complètement et l'idée que justin
trudeau jette de l'huile sur le feu en
disant je vais tenir mon bout sur les
vaccins et un peu singulière dans la
mesure où
il ya aussi dit qu'il fallait faire
preuve de compassion que les gens qui
manifestaient comme ça avait vécu
certainement 17 mois de pandémie à la
dure comme à peu près tout le monde
c'est pas comme s'ils avaient dit ces
gens là savent pas de quoi ils parlent
cela dit c'est clair que les libéraux
espèrent compter des points sur les
conservateurs battu par ce concept car
je crois pas quand même les gens qui
sont anti vaccins ont plus tendance à
voter conservateur que néo-démocrate
bloc québécois ou libérale et demain
quelqu'un qu'on entend pas souvent
depuis le début de la campagne le
premier ministre fort dans notorious va
rendre un grand service et autour parce
qu'en principe il va annoncer qu'ils
furent gagnées à l'idée d'un passeport
bec snal ce qui va un peu enlevé la
tentative de dire vous voyez ces gens-là
et des conservateurs versus des libéraux
des vaccins j'osais je rappelle aux gens
que monsieur trudeau à proposer la
vaccination obligatoire fin septembre
pour tous les employés fédéraux pour les
transports etc je blanchet hier encore à
l'émission le
digne pas obligatoire il faut comprendre
il faut pas braquer ces gens là donc
monsieur trudeau cette manifestation la
halle est là bien dit on a eu
l'impression ça leur donner des
munitions et de l'énergie pour reprendre
ce thème là
oui je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce
que mes deux collègues viennent de dire
d'autant plus que c'est pas particulier
à au canada ce qui se passe en ce moment
cette espèce de mouvement à la sauce
trump et qu'on voit déjà extrêmement
agressif qui sont par crescendo depuis
des mois ça a commencé avec le mouvement
à petit masque ensuite à petit il mesure
salutaire en général ensuite anti
vaccins et la antilibérale carrément là
puisque ces gens-là identifie justin
trudeau comme étant le porteur de ce mal
dans leur propre vision des choses dont
les chefs d'état et les chefs de partis
ont une responsabilité en ce moment et
je pense que monsieur blanchet très sage
d'en prendre note
c'est justement de tracer une frontière
est de dire clairement que ce genre de
comportement la démocratie ce n'est pas
acceptable
celui qui jette de l'huile sur le feu ou
ceux qui le font ce sont ces
manifestants là c'est pas le
oui il ya soit sur le fond des choses et
aussi vous avez parfaitement raison sur
le plan tactique le plan électoral on
sait que justin trudeau tout à coup
vient de retrouver une certaine énergie
pour ne pas dire d'énergie surtout on va
écouter l'autre extrême monsieur trudeau
sur ce sujet là justement où là il a il
veut faire du judo sur le la joute
politique on lui coupe le manque de
leadership de monsieur autour il
monsieur blanchet au niveau des
vaccinations
tenterait de deux
de rire
des sacrifices que tellement de
canadiens ont fait pendant cette
pandémie et continue à faire en se
faisant vacciner
ça prend du leadership sans équivalent
on le voit que les libéraux quand il
parle de ça allait on a l'impression
qu'ils sont plus à l'aise
les premiers jours de la campagne avait
pas de tourner exactement comme le
souhaitait justin trudeau et son équipe
la classe qui avait parlé de vaccination
obligatoire pour les employés fédéraux
rapidement la question de ok mais on
fait comment si quelqu'un veut pas se
faire vacciner est ce qu'on le suspense
qu'on leur envoie est-ce que ce qu'il
est confiné dans le fond d'un bureau
puis le bain où le jeu des trous savais
pas trop quoi répondre à ce conseil du
trésor se prédit le patron va
s'expliquer avec les syndicats donc
c'est devenu nébuleux donc à donner
prise aux faits qu'il y avait peut-être
lancer sur un peu en l'air puis qu'elle
l'ait pas vraiment préparé la réponse à
tous ceux donc ça se fait écraser assez
rapidement mais plus les provinces vont
de l'avant avec la vaccination
obligatoire que sur les travailleurs de
la santé que sont les universités au
canada anglais qui impose la vaccination
sur leur campus pour le personnel pour
les étudiants le passeport vaccinale en
ontario d'oxford et contre le
soudainement il pour sa voix hier à
alimenter le débat quand on cadre le
débat de manière plus large et en élite
lui a été avant ce type de débat là mais
elle a du bon côté de la clôture et
c'est pour ça que l'on essaie de
récupérer cet avantage là que peut-être
pas eu comme il le souhaitait dans le
début de la campagne qu'est ce que ça va
se maintenir je pas certain mais c'est
clair qu actuellement il se sent
meilleure position que lors du premier
acte de la campagne entend
on au bull et renault tous le vendredi
soir
je pense que monsieur trudeau avait même
pas eu la chance de parler de ce qui
s'était passé à son propre rallye dire
s'il y avait des partisans conservateurs
et il y en avait qui étaient là ils ne
sont plus bienvenue dans mon parti c'est
comprendre le danger si ce qui est
intéressant de ce qu'on a entendu dit
françois blanchet avancé que la chose la
plus dangereuse
quand on regarde les sondages 75 à 80 %
des gens sont vaccinés la même
proportion venue des mesures
restrictives pour des gens qui se font
pas vacciner
la dernière chose qu'un chef de parti
bouder et renault tout le conflit
extraordinairement beats et être associé
à ces gens qui manifestent
changé conclusion là dessus
oui mais je pense que non
avec avec votre table hier on a en effet
mis la table en véranda les débats aussi
comment les positions vont s'opposer là
dessus parce que bon justin trudeau il
faut la vaccination obligatoire
et il prend soin branché ne l'est pas et
jack meeting les malgré la grande
proximité du midi avec les syndicats
les syndicats qui eux-mêmes s'oppose à
la vaccination obligatoire il fallait
entendre monsieur au tour hier avec avec
vous se vanter d'avoir la même position
que les syndicats ah c'est quand même
assez
ça va être intéressant les débats y en a
judge à tva le prochain c'est le 8
septembre
d'ailleurs parenthèses les francophones
sont des moments importants à cette
campagne
chantage ou voix souris
vous aimerez peut probablement ma
réponse disons qu'avec elle ok une des
raisons pour lesquelles bas d'abord la
proposition certes qui a donné le truc
dit hier que moi j'ai trouvé
extraordinairement utile pour des
électeurs en passant
copier bout que ce sont des chefs qui
s'épargne quand même une visite chacun
leurs lots de
vecteurs donc en termes de temps c'est
efficace mais d'autre part et c'est ça
que vous aimerez probablement moins la
décision de tva de se retirer du
consortium alors que tva aux tirs quand
même un auditoire conséquentes au vu
pour conséquence d'amener plus de débat
en français qu'en anglais à tout prendre
c'était court des lecteurs francophones
pas une mauvaise décision mais ça reste
patrice que les francophones et je vous
suis d'accord avec vous chanter mais ça
reste patrice que les francophones ont
trois rendez-vous pour mieux comprendre
la campagne électorale des meilleurs
radio-canada plus que les étudiants
puissent les endort les anglophones sont
limités à un seul exercice du même type
alors qu'ils auraient tellement de
sujets de débat fin je peux comprendre
les anglos d'être un petit peu
jaloux aujourd'hui de l'espace qu'on
installe ce côté francophone très bien
c'est pour ça que probablement la
prochaine campagne électorale les
anglophones
une fois n'est pas coutume mais c'était
le point de départ plus calés oui aux
élégantes à
2,7 et il y avait du monde un jour ce
qu'une soi même surpris je ne
commencerai pas à danser léché mais ça
nous arrive il y avait beaucoup de monde
hier bon environnement comme il reste le
temps qu'on me reste combien de sept ans
qu'on a le temps d'écouter on va coûter
rapidement les extraits envier
canada a perdu dix ans sous le règne du
parti conservateur qui propose
maintenant revenir en arrière aux
anciennes cible climatique des années un
prénom et françois blanchet a une vision
à géométrie variable de ce qui est bon
pour l'environnement est ce qu'on est en
train de voir maintenant de monsieur
blanchette c'est qu'encore une fois
c'est pleine contradiction et ils
essayent de se dire que c'est tout le
monde qui se trompe s'il n'y a pas de
contradiction puisqu'il le dit mais
voyons je le sais qu'il ya des gens qui
sont pas d'accord avec la décision
d'acheter un oléoduc et d'investir tous
les profits dans ce virage vert
mais je l'assumé
je réitère à l'intention de monsieur
guilbeault et de monsieur trudeau que
eux ils disent une chose en matière
environnementale et font le compte hier
le contraire en matière pétrolière et
moi je continuerai à défendre résolument
la nécessité de concilier la création de
richesse le développement et et
l'environnement et les projets verts il
faut concilier l'avenir économique passe
par là et il lire pas chez nous d'époque
l'isie dans les propositions
est ce que il reste très peu de ma faute
est ce que au moins cette fois ci on va
parler jusqu'à la fin d'environnement
dans cette campagne très rapidement vous
3 josé
ben on va en parler parce que parce
qu'ils vont en parler les chefs mais bon
pour une fois je vous dirais que on n'a
pas lâché
climatique est plus gros que les pieds
là on a des positions quand même très
différent entre celle du parti libéral
conservateur
weekly la chanteuse
oui parce qu une différence réelle
effectivement mon plan un plus gros que
l'outil c'est vrai dans ce cas ci on
tait libéraux et les conservateurs qu'on
aime ce sport monsieur autour veut
réduire les ambitions
en matière de changements climatiques
que les libéraux ont mises en place et
d'autre part c'est vrai qu'il ya une
semaine mais entre les vidéos et des
conservateurs il ya aussi monsieur hutus
qui vous a dit hier ça a surpris
beaucoup de gens en colombie-britannique
produit il ya les en construire d'autres
oléoduc
alec conclusions la réponse est oui
d'abord parce que c'est l'un des trois
sujets dont les électeurs veulent le
plus à temps de parler ça se confirme de
sondage en sondage et ensuite c'est l'un
des rares sujets qui peut faire marquer
des points parti politique encore le
britannique en ontario et au québec
closes et les élections vont jouer donc
oui on va parler d'environnement jusqu'à
la fin cet exemplaire merci beaucoup
merci à très bientôt au revoir en soirée
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit